all over the country statues of
Confederate generals and other
controversial historical figures are
being removed you've heard about this
they're being removed or sometimes
they're being torn down now most people
are really glad to finally see some of
these statues gone but not everybody's
on board one of those people is joining
me via satellite please welcome the
Bob's Big Boy statue oh hey well thank
you so much for being here first off how
do I address you is it Bob or do I call
you big boy that's pretty confusing so
bob is my dad and I'm his big boy so but
you know what you just call me Kevin
it's less awkward okay great so Kevin
how do you feel about all these statues
being taken down I'm terrified
I've been sleeping with one eye open I
may look like I'm smiling but inside I
am crapping my overalls well oh you know
you shouldn't be scared I don't think
you have anything to worry about Kevin
you're just a fast-food mascot nothing
to worry about
Oh trust me I know where this is going
first they come for the Confederates
then it's the slave owners then it's
probably gonna be the lawn gnomes and
then pretty soon all of us fast-food
guys are on the guillotine that's why
I've been packing heat Conan okay no no
you shouldn't you shouldn't be packing
heat don't do that I've got a walk-in
closet calm down no no this whole
movement isn't about statues but about
what kind of people the statues
represent and it's not like you've got
anything wrong
oh no Conant I've done terrible things
really like what off the record well no
this is a live TV show thank you Wow
where do I start
tax evasion some like credit card fraud
a ton of DUIs
it look that's that's not good it's
pretty bad but it's not as bad and some
of the things these stands blow but I'm
just getting started
selling human organs on the dark web
cockfighting and I mean both kinds I
told Harvey Weinstein to use that Walker
I wrote that song jespah Seto
you wrote this besito I did it was a
moment of weakness I shouldn't have
written it let alone released it oh God
okay you know what I know I'm not
letting you off the hook
i I do hope someone tears you down take
him away guys so long Kevin and I won't
he sorry's you go to the very end you
gotta admire him are you dead yet Kevin
[Music]
anyway that was Bob's Big Boy
aka Kevin he's been torn down